[Music]
oh snap what's happening i see y'all
what's up everybody man
big game today real big game today
uh
celtics
my golden state warriors
what y'all talking about in the comments
i'm in the comments right now before we
get this show started i'm trying to
figure out what y'all talking about what
y'all want to talk about what's some of
the bets that y'all like
what's on your mind uh
what some of the bets that you guys were
talking about with your friends we're
trying to look for scoops we're looking
for angles here we're looking for scoops
we're looking for angles
if you guys go to my instagram story
i was talking to my buddy who sent me a
bet
um
i'll give you guys a bet before the show
starts why not
he told me to take dreamline green point
total over today
we so we're gonna see
we're gonna see my man brett is in the
comments
saying the celtics about to claim these
dubs
i don't know if i can agree with that
brett
but the celtics
whatever whatever show's gonna start in
probably like 30 seconds so
i'll wait to give you guys my takes then
right now i'm gonna cool down it's hot
in california
i don't know where you guys are watching
from but uh
it's hot outside out here i live in the
bay area usually it's cooler temperature
but uh
it's real hot outside so uh got the
handy-dandy towel with me and they got
stripes because the towel has earned
these stripes for sure
tau has earned his stripes for sure
i'm in the chat i'm in the chat looking
for you guys to take seeing what you
guys are talking about talking about
sam richmond sam richman is in the chat
let's be great in fact let's be great
today let's in fact be great
uh
[Music]
hey be money i think b money
i think it's time to get this show
started be money you guys don't know b
money is my td
he is my td uh back in new york so be
money let's get this show started
everybody everybody in the mama is out
there talking about
the nba finals
and i know i know
i'm a warriors fan everybody and they
mama know that i'm a warriors fan
everybody and they mama know that i'm
gonna rock with the bay area soil no
matter what when lose or draw i am going
to rock with my soil
i understand i totally understand
you guys are giving me rift on br
betting in the comments you guys are
also giving me rift in my dms you guys
are talking that talk
but do not be alarmed do not be alarmed
do not be too happy you celtics fans
because
the warrior's been here before
we actually been here for four yes i
said we
because
i'm part of the team i got a ring really
do got a ring but i'm part of a team us
in the bay area we feel together we're
together so us we yes we've been here
before 2015 i'll go back to it
the lebron james-led cavaliers
the lebron james-led cavaliers was going
into game four up 2-1 against the golden
state warriors
guess what that golden state warriors
team did
they went on and won three in a row
and that was against lebron james i do
not think i don't think that this
celtics team has anybody we can measure
up against lebron james granite tatum is
really good tatum is really really good
but he is not on lebron james level
nowhere near it i would say especially
lebron in his prime i don't think
tatum's nowhere near it
but that leads me to my first point that
leads me to my first point the series
been very interesting before i get to my
point the series has been very very very
interesting game one warriors were up i
want to say 15 ended up losing it
celtics scored 40 points in the first
quarter
i mean not the first quarter the fourth
quarter the fourth quarter they scored
40 points in the fourth quarter
and the warriors ended up losing that
one game two warriors bounced back they
bounced back with a a really good solid
win in san francisco
and uh things were neck and neck game
three game three celtics went up big
warriors climbed back but the celtics
had what it took in order to take game
three
game four is tonight
but what i want to talk to you guys
about is i didn't even know honestly i
didn't even know this was a thing until
i dibbled and dabbed onto fanduel that's
what i like to do i like to go on
fanduel
search for some bets and i diblin dabbed
onto fanduel it is hot let me wipe my
face man because it is hot
in california but i dibbled and dabbed
and i came across
a series spread i never heard of that
before series spread and i saw the
golden state warriors
plus one and a half and not only were
they plus one and a half but
that was plus money
now if we're talking trends of this
series it's been going back and forth
back and forth back and forth
i don't know i don't think the celtics
can win this one in six i don't i think
if the celtics do win in fact
they win in seven
so if they win in seven
that means
the series bet of plus one and a half
for the golden state warriors that is
plus money
will cash
so i'm just throwing angles at you guys
i'm just throwing angles that is why i'm
here i'm here to throw angles and angles
only
so if you guys think the celtics can
take in and six which i really don't
don't bet it but if you guys think the
celtics
is gonna win and it's gonna be a
competitive series and it's gonna go
back to san francisco in a game seven
hey
bet
the series
spread i got a special guest for you
guys though i i got a special guest
i call him s dot you guys might call him
sam richmond
but i actually i heard that my man's not
ready sam what is going on bro like
you're not ready when we're ready for
you but that is okay because i can still
talk golden state warriors i can still
talk draymond green actually in fact my
man draymond
was very vocal he was very very vocal
after the loss
and he said that he had to play better
draymond the golden state warriors in
fact need you to play better draymond
knows that he has to play better
the golden state warriors steve kerr
they know draymond have to play better i
was talking to my buddies before i came
on the show
and i was talking to him and i was just
telling them the importance of if
draymond was a threat
now even if he was 25
of a threat
if if i'm a defender and i fear draymond
green
actually going to the rim and scoring
rather than just passing the ball so
therefore say your defender and you got
draymond coming at you and you he's a
threat to score so
that makes you think that makes you
think am i going to jump out and defend
draymond from scoring am i going to
prevent draymond from scoring and if i
do that guess who's open in the corner
guess who's open in the wing steph curry
clay thompson so that's the importance
of draymond green
in this warriors offense and i think
that he's going to have to he's going to
have to i think that he's going to make
an effort to
score tonight i think he's going to make
an effort to score tonight i also think
he's going to make an effort to rebound
better i also think he's going to make
an effort
to throw more assists this is a big game
for draymond a really really big game
for draymond
and uh i wonder how he's gonna bounce
back i'm into these comments though i
meant to these comments actually we're
calling no longer comments we're no
longer calling into comments i'm into
the chat i am into the chat
i heard that my man sam's back but sam
you're gonna have to wait brother you
are gonna have to wait because i'm into
this chat and i see
bk37 says fade tatum he's played too
well the last couple games
it's time for another eight point thirty
percent shooting night actually let's
bring in sam because i want to talk to
sam about that before you give your pick
sam
the chat is talking
the chat is chirping
they're saying
that jason tatum is not going off
tonight
sam i want to know
your thoughts
do you think this is a spot where jason
tatum do not go off tonight
if the chat and i can't see the chat
because my internet sucks so i had to
move to my phone instead of my computer
so i cannot look at the chat but if the
chat likes jason tatum under then they
are going to absolutely hate my first
pick of the night uh which i feel like
is a good segue for for me to get my
pick but i'll wait for you uh-oh
no no no no don't wait for me sam don't
wait for me at all do your thing do your
thing give him your pick start off how
you want to start
wow okay so you're fading my guy in the
comments
sam's fading my guy in the comments
there it is you're going with tatum over
26 and a half sam you have to talk to me
talk to the people
what's your reasoning behind this
is sam frozen
sam we we gotta figure we gotta figure
out what's going on in atlanta sam is it
the internet or is it you we know what's
going on in california we got a heat
wave we got a heat wave going on over
here and i'm sweating like a
like a like like like i'm steph curry
playing in the fourth quarter of nba
finals but um
we got to figure out what's going on
with sam sam i got to sing you an att uh
my att account get that wi-fi oh there
he is sam's back say sam's back no more
jokes about your wi-fi you're back
you're going with tatum tatum
over tonight talk to the people what's
the reason behind it
look he hasn't this just feels like a
big tatum night like he hasn't exactly
gone off in the series but the thing i
like about it is he's still getting his
shots up he's up at like 19
20 shots per game in this series
but he's shooting 32 percent and even
shooting around 32 percent he's getting
near 26 28 points in the last few games
i just feel like he's too good of a
player not to
not to get back on track and get that
shooting percentage back to 40 45
percent
and i also have a stat that i stole from
our producer ryan uh i had ryan look up
some stats for me before the show um and
he told me that jason tatum is averaging
30 points per game uh
and
at one after the series goes to game in
games four through seven in the last few
rounds so as these series have gone
deeper tatum has gotten more comfortable
and gone off and i think that continues
tonight so i think we're getting to
tatum bounce back sam
i mean okay i respect the tatum take i i
totally respect that
and i do think that that actually
probably can hit i mean i've been on
record saying that the go to state
warriors do not really defend superstars
well
we've seen it in
in round one
against the denver nuggets and jokic
we've seen it in round two against the
grizzlies and job we've seen it in round
three against the mavericks and luca
so i i i can agree with your point there
but i just want to talk about
bro you have
interns or you have other people going
to look up stats for you like what is i
need somebody to look up some stats for
me
what is this say hey sam's comes on a
couple shows and he has interns going to
go grab stats for him now
well first of all ryan is not an intern
ryan is a legend we need to we need to
make sure we give rise ryan is a legend
ryan is elizabeth i'm sorry you were not
behind the scenes
that without peeling back the card too
much
is our friends on the app team a good
friend of mine stephen favetti hit me up
and he said we need you know that push
notification that all of our followers
get before the show that has like a
little stat to watch the show he was
like i need a stat for tayden for the
show and i i had to go get a haircut
because my hair looked awful so i said
ryan can you can you help me out can you
help a brother out and find me a staff
that i could send to our good friend
stephen fibetti to send the alert and uh
and ryan delivered and then i spoke for
the show as well so i love little inside
baseball i love hot
yeah i love how you went in behind the
curtain you know what i mean and let the
people know
what happened and ryan we know that
you're not an intern well i know that uh
but
sam i guess this is a perfect spot for
you to go into your second pick and
hopefully i like this one
this is a good segue i'm just i'm
keeping it going
taylor first basket baby plus 550.
uh like i said i think i think this is a
tatum game uh i went back and forth on
this but i do think this is a tatum game
and if you're gonna throw a dart throw
plus 550 is is pretty nice i
i think people are focusing on jaylen
brown a little bit too much i think his
number was like plus 380. this k this
team still runs through jason tatum i
think they're going to want to get him
going i think he he pops a three ball to
start the game i don't know what the the
first method of basket tatum three ball
is but if that's like plus 2000 or
higher i like that bad boy as well but
yeah we're all on the j train today this
is our tatum game hey i don't know if
it's you sam and your picks or if it's
this california heat wave that's making
me sweat because uh
you're all over the seas over there
brother and um i don't know if i'm
gelling with this but hold on let me hop
in the chat real quick let me hop in the
chat let me see what they talking about
uh i got ritter says
a first basket pick from sam sam i guess
the people
there
ritter is trying to say you don't really
choose first baskets is that like
a credible source is redo a credible
source to say that
that is true like i think we talked
about this a little bit last week i'm
usually kind of a loser with betting i
just like bet straight bets and i don't
have too much fun with the props and
stuff but like we said i got i got my
celtics future i got my warriors future
so i'm kind of i'm looking to
uh i don't want to steal your phrase um
dibble dib and dabble is that what you
said dab and dibble yeah dab dibbling
and dab
yeah i just sounded like an idiot just
now but uh i'm i'm kind of sprinkling
around i'm playing around a little bit
but i will say i knew that you weren't
gonna like my first two bets so i wanted
to get them out of the way as soon as
possible i think i'll have a few that
you like and then i'm going to come back
with one that you're going to hate i
don't know why i organized it in that
way i kind of just like put these pieces
of paper together in random order but i
think i'm going to get you on my side
for the next few
you sandwiched it up you sandwich it up
the negative the bad on the on the ends
and then inside you know it's nice and
well done and some good juicy uh bets or
whatever we want to call it go ahead
that leads us go ahead bet number three
sam talk to the people what are you
rocking with
all right next one
is under 214 and i i think you're gonna
like this because we've done some shows
before and
you you lean under in some of these
games with great defenses and that's
exactly what we have here
here's my take with this game
and i got to do the the hand gestures to
make it sound like i'm smarter than i am
but i feel like stylistically tonight's
game is going to be a lot more like game
two
than it was game three and game one
where the overs hit i think this is a
game where again we saw in game two when
the warriors were really really
desperate they came out
and draymond led the way and the energy
and the defensive focus was there from
the start and while i do like the
celtics tonight i do think that you're
gonna see that warriors defensive effort
from the first whistle to the last um
and i think they're gonna come out with
a lot of energy and i think like i think
there's just some other factors i like
here at the under as you get deeper in
the series legs get tired this is the
only game in the series where there's
only one day of rest i think that's
gonna factor in we're really getting to
the end of this long playoff run for
both of these teams i think legs get
tired in general and then and i actually
maybe i lied that you were going to like
this because i don't want to bring this
up in front of you but a little
concerned about steph curry being a
little hurt and i think that plays into
the under so i'm actually curious your
take on this death stuff uh obviously
he's playing tonight do you think he's
gonna be fine as a warriors fan are you
concerned about it all or are you just
trust steph
sam i was on my phone looking up
instagram checking out my friends over
there at 95.7 the game
was on their instagram feed shout out to
whitley she is the social media
coordinator over there shout out to her
so anyway uh i was checking out their
instagram and i saw stephen curry
warming up sam
and i watched
i watched
and i watched i watched it over and over
and over again and they had multiple
clips multiple clips different angles
and i didn't see a limp sam i didn't see
a [ __ ] i didn't see a slow step in his
step i didn't i didn't see anything to
have me on alarm that steph is not going
to step tonight so
i i did not see anything but one thing i
do want to say and i know the celtics
fans might get on me about this one but
throughout this playoffs
the celtics consistently went on like
some scoring droughts they went on some
school we saw it in game two they went
on a big scoring drought that game went
under
sam is history is the trends gonna
repeat itself i'm trying to
you know bring good vibes to your
underbed i'm trying to bring the vibes
to your underbed uh but the celtics
sometimes they go on those scoring
droughts
and can that help sam in his under bed
tonight i don't know we will see sam
you gave us three
let's talk four
what's the fourth bet your rockaway
you're you're gonna like this one this
is and this go this goes along with the
under like i said i think
start to finish you
we are going to get a desperate and
hungry golden state warriors team
tonight and there is no better
embodiment of that than draymond green
i this is i am so excited to watch dream
on green play basketball tonight like
this is going to be this is going to be
like game two this is going to be a
dream i'll spoil my next bet too
draymond over five yeah i'm going all
draymond okay
this is this is the game for draymond
this is where he sets his tone and you
talked about like what you saw on the on
the 95.7 instagram i i like that i love
that in this new age of betting we can
kind of like get info from instagram i
got a little info oh yeah from the
draymond green podcast which i listened
to and he talked about how going into
game three
he he wasn't himself because he let
everyone get in his head
after
you know what happened in game two with
like messing with the refs and getting
into it you know just kind of being a
disrupter which what he did and he
talked about that he was like i let too
many people get in my head i wasn't
myself in game three i need to just be
the guy who got me to where i am which
is a great player so
i think he's gonna get i think he's
gonna you know talk a little smack with
the crowd tonight i think he's gonna be
pumping them up to be louder when they
start the draymond chance i think he is
going to be getting in jalen brown's
face i think he's going to be going
after everyone uh and and then i also
think he knows that he needs to play
great for this warriors team
to win so i think he's going to be
massive on the glass i think the key
stat that everyone talked about after
game three was the celtics getting 15
offensive rebounds i think he knows they
got to clean that up he's the guy that's
gonna go down there do the dirty work
clean up the glass and then i also think
he's just gonna be gonna imprint his
force on this game and also rack up over
five and a half assists so
take draymond over this is this is the
draymond game i love your take
i love your take sam and i'll i'll tell
you why i love your take
draymond plays well the warriors win
so my man sam just basically said
draymond's gonna come out he's going
over rebounds over assists i'm going
over on the points
draymond has a good game that usually
tends to mean that the golden state
warriors
walks out of whatever arena that they're
in
with a w
but i'll leave that i'll leave that
there
and i want to know what's the sixth bet
because you kind of teed me up sam you
told me that i won't like it so
i'm ready for it right now
so
so
my internet when my internet went out i
think you talked about the exact
opposite of this bet
i am going to give out celtics minus one
and a half games uh i'm sorry to do that
greg i'm sorry
i i talked you know we can play back
this tape after you know steph wins
finals mvp and the warriors are
celebrating coming back and winning the
series
i think the boston celtics are the
better basketball team i think they win
tonight uh
i i i think the home i think the home
team will win every game the rest of the
series i think celtics will win tonight
i think you'll get a really big
motivational edge for the warriors back
at home and game five i think they'll
win that game and then i think the
boston celtics uh close the deal and if
they do that if the series plays out
like that i don't know if you remember
greg i gave out a 28-1 you know me i
would never brag about a pick i gave out
a 28-1 correct order of games bet last
week that had celtics winning game one
warriors winning game two celtics
winning three and four warriors winning
five celtics winning in six
three legs down baby that is that's on
the table that could still cash so i
know that you personally don't want that
to cash
but for me yeah i would like to have
cash um but yeah man you know i think
there's i think these teams are very
close but i think boston is slightly
better but
i'm sorry to do that to you
that's very debatable to call them
better is very very debatable
um
also brother
i don't know sam i i
you you made a point okay you made a
point that makes sense but just let's
take tonight's game out of it let's take
tonight's game out of it because
i think the warriors are going to bounce
back and then you said
each team that's at home is gonna win
the games that are that they're playing
at home so warriors win tonight let's
take tonight out of that
warriors win game five
boston wins game six
dubs taken in seven that's how i see it
it's just hard i don't know bro you
really think that the
that they can win in six what are you
thinking six or five boston winning in
six or five
i think six and i will say this i do
think i think if the war like this is
like your very cliche like sports radio
take that everyone says but it's like i
think whoever wins tonight is going to
win the series i think if the warriors
win tonight which like i think is very
possible like i think these teams are
very close i think the celtics are
slightly better and i think when they
took home court advantage um away in
game one i think that was huge but i
think i wouldn't be stunned if the
warriors win tonight if they did i think
it's going seven and i think the
warriors would win in seven like we
talked about last week i think if it
goes if it goes seven games i'm gonna
trust the home team which wins game
sevens about eighty percent of the time
um and the veteran experience of the
warriors so and then and also again not
not a big look at me brag about my bet
guy but i also bet warriors to win 4-3
so you know if that happens
i'm just feeling great man i'm just
feeling great i think i think it's
either celtics and six or warriors in
seven i think i'm in one of those series
bets hey um yeah i mean this is this is
great this is great for me i'm i'm on
top of the world sam you just you just
can't lose huh you just can't lose like
you're you're just winning no matter
what i like that mentality you know that
winners only mentality so i i'm gelling
with you bro i'm right there with you
with the mentality i just don't know
about some of your picks just some of
them is just
a little in left field but you know
your heart's there so that's all that
matters that that is all
that uh matters let me hop into the chat
though sam because i want to see what
they're talking about
uh bk37 says experience will win sam you
talked about this let's let's talk about
this for a little bit experience i think
this is we're about to get into
i wanna let's make our own phrase the
dog days of the series that means
the critical games the the the games
that the experience actually matters
do you think this celtics team can
falter out
because the warriors have more
experience than them in these crucial
critical
games later in the series
i think it's possible but
man i was really impressed with boston
winning that game one on the road um i
was about to say oracle at chase center
um and i don't they've just been so
battle tested this playoffs they've had
three elimination games against they had
giannis
i think yeah two elimination games
against giannis one against the heat on
the road like they don't have the
experience but this team is super battle
tested so
i the only place where i think that
experience will really be a big
difference is i think if it gets to a
game seven i just think i just think
that's gonna be a different animal back
in chase center um with the warriors
having home court and like i said i
don't i i don't mean to keep repeating
that stat but i do think it's very
important of game seven the home team
wins eighty percent of the time and then
you factor in that steph has been there
and draymond has been there and and clay
has been there that's why i think you're
going to get a very that's why i think
the warriors are going to play really
desperate tonight but i also think
you're going to get a really desperate
celtics team tonight as well because i
think they probably know that if they
drop one of these home games they're
going to be in big trouble they to me
they have to win this series and six
their approach would be when the two
home games be champions because i think
if they drop one they're going to be in
big trouble
big trouble and i agree with you s dot
we got your six but man it's my time bro
it's my time let me hop in here
you know me bro i'm only looking for
angles i'm only looking for angles
and i got a question to the audience i'm
about to pose two bets which one is the
better bet sam i also will love your
take on this we're going to start it off
with clay thompson
klay thompson is a very very streaky
player if you follow the warriors if you
follow his career
clay goes down he goes high he goes down
he goes high
when he's low he's low
but when he's high he's on fire
sam last game my man clay kind of broke
out of his little slump he scored 25
points last game
and uh
i think he can do that tonight
clay usually sees the ball goes through
the net
that tends to mean that usually means
he's going to continue that hot streak
he's going to continue that fire he's
going to continue that trend
we've seen it we've seen it time after
time after time
let's look at last series sam let me
pull it up let's look at last series
my man clay thompson
32 points in the decide in the clincher
32 points in the clincher
before that he gave he put up 12. before
that he 19 15 50 30 in the grizzlies
like my man clay thompson his numbers
are
relatively they're there they're they're
around there they're around there
anyways i'm gonna get to my point
because i want to move on to my next bet
sam 25 plus 25 points in the golden
state warriors to win i can see that
happening tonight you said it the golden
state warriors if they win this game
they can win the series i think they
know that this is how they can go and
get home field advantage back just win
tonight you got home for the advantage
for the next three
so i can see my man klay thompson going
out there and putting on the performance
he had 25 last time continuing that
trend of
once he's hot clay stays hot
get 25 points go get the win that is
sitting at plus 650 i love those odds
let's move over kevon looney kevon
looney my man kevin looney i would say
he's been a real important factor for
the golden state warriors this
postseason
he's kind of like the team mvp the way
he's been rebounding the ball
it's been remarkable the way he's been
rebounding has been remarkable but sam
i'm looking for angles and i'm looking
for trends
last time the golden state warriors won
against these boston celtics my man
kevin looney scored 12 points in 21
minutes
steve kerr i don't know why
he deducted kevon looney minutes in game
three he only had 17 minutes scored six
points i think that he's going to get a
bump in minutes today
with him getting a bump in minutes i
think that his point total is going to
go up so i need kevon looney to score 10
points the golden state warriors win
that's sitting at plus 850
we are only looking for angles here in
angles only
let's pull up the graphics so i can show
you guys so i could talk to you guys
klay thompson
25 points and the golden state warriors
to win plus 650 my man clay seen it
last game he's seen the ball go in the
in the whole last game so i think he's
going to continue to see the ball go in
this game in the golden state words we
know they need to win this game in order
to stay in the series kevin looney
when he plays good the warriors play
good 10 points in the last time
they won in game two he scored 12. i
could see my guy going out there and
getting 10 and the warriors to win
sitting at plus 8 20. sam talk to me i
thought it was plus 850 but i guess it
went down to plus 820. the odds makers
know what's up they know what time it is
sam talk to me talk to the people which
one of these is the better bet
so
i like what you said about kavon looty
getting more minutes tonight because i
think that's i think exactly that is
going to happen uh i think kerr got a
little shook in game three based on the
celtics just draining threes and he kind
of wanted to match them match boston
with offensive firepower so he went a
little small but to your point they got
crushed on the glass as a result of it
and that ended up being the difference
kind of backfired so i think if he's
looking for an adjustment i think you're
going to see yes looney back in his more
normal minutes
i like it my concern is that
i think he's going to get a lot of
rebounds i'm just not sure he's going to
get a lot of points i think i i said
this the other day like his offensive
rebounds seem to be more impactful than
anyone that anyone else is in the league
because he always finds like clay or
steph or someone out there for three he
just has very good vision like that and
i think he's going to get a lot of
rebounds i just think it's going to turn
more into assists than points i like the
clay angle because to your point like
yeah he's very streaky like he could
have nine points a night he could also
have 35
i think they might rely on clay a little
bit more tonight again because of the
steph is a little banged up angle i
think draymond is going to be out there
looking for clay
to kind of take some of that pressure
off steph i think steph probably going
to be looking at clay to take some of
the pressure off him so i think i think
that is the recipe right like i think if
they are going to win you're going to
need a big play game so you're basically
going to get warriors money line
not apples to apples but at plus 650 for
a normal recipe for them to win the game
i think is a really good price
come on now sam talk to the people hey
i'm just throwing angles at you guys
it's up for you to grab it and go with
it but i just want to just throw an
angle at you guys so you guys can think
about it ponder it and then make
your decision um
but klay thompson 25 points in the
golden state warriors to win i like that
kevon looney you made some good points
sam you made some really good points i
think kevon looney can score i've been
seeing it throughout this playoffs steph
curry draymond green usually drive into
the hole
the the defender
gravitates towards steph and sometimes
draymond whoever it is that's driving
jordan poole next thing you know my man
looney sitting right there for the easy
lay-up the easy dunk i can just see a
couple of more of those opportunities
happening for looney today if his
minutes are
bumped up from last game also you also
touched on the offensive rebound sam you
get an offensive rebound you're right
there put that thing back up so uh we'll
see we'll see i like both of these bets
you guys let me know which ones you guys
are rocking with michael ritter says in
the comments that he is
writing or that he likes the looney bit
more i bet he you do michael ritter
because it's better odds but i like both
of them
one thing though sam as i'm dibbling and
dabbling i'm on fanduel right now i am
literally on fanduel right now
dibbling and dabbling through and
something that caught my eye sam oh whoa
whoa this one this one's crazy wait the
producer is telling me wait we have a
tweet for let's pull up the tweet let's
pull up the tweet so i can explain this
one is real life crazy sam
read this one and read this one
carefully third quarter warriors
continue to be incredible game one you
see the results
game two yes you you see the results
game three
nothing change you still see the results
look at the bottom you can see the total
points in this series the golden state
warriors compared to those boston
celtics in the third quarter
sam as i'm looking on fanduel i see
warriors third
quarter winner
sitting that plus 108 it is plus money
sam my mom always told me if it ain't
broke
don't fix it
i don't think this one needs to be fixed
sam talk to me
do you think the warriors can uh
go and grab the third quarter yet again
in this game
i i think i i agree with you i think you
have to trust at this point if it was
just these three games with the warriors
where they uh were dominant in the third
quarter maybe that was one thing but
they've been doing this for the entire
steph era third quarter warriors is a
thing they're absolutely dominant the
plus money is super interesting but you
know what we're not talking enough about
is like second quarter celtics or fourth
quarter celtics because those fourth
quarter numbers for boston are actually
pretty similar in the series than like
the third quarter warrior stuff but we
won't get into that we'll we'll just
talk three quarter warriors propaganda
but i i think you have to like it uh
they've just been too good in that over
the last three four years
sam honestly bro i love your angle i
like money i love your angle talk about
that for celtics fourth quarter hey talk
about it brother because money is money
and they have been getting it done in
the fourth quarter we've seen time and
time out but we also have been seeing
the warriors getting it done in that
third quarter and it's plus money but
sam bro my time with you has been well i
i've enjoyed this going back and forth
with you about uh celtics warriors uh i
i i still we gotta offline on some
things we gotta get get your head
straight on some stuff that uh we
discussed today but that is okay
uh hey
till next time brother till next time my
name is greg ivory that is sam richmond
we
are up out of here
peace
[Music]
you